characters come and go every season on
the walking dead but sometimes an
actor's departure can be somewhat
controversial
from career moves to behind the scenes
drama here are the real reasons why
these walking dead actors left the show
after joining the walking dead in season
two maggie green evolved into one of the
show's strongest and most important
characters
leading the hilltop and the militia all
while fighting off countless walkers
but maggie disappeared from the walking
dead in season nine
off in search of new bands of survivors
actress lauren cohen tried to nail down
a new contract with amc
and asked for the pay raise that was
coming to her as a veteran cast member
cohen said on andy cohen live it wasn't
actually that i was asking for it
it's that my contract had finished so
that's a pretty standard renegotiation
cohen and producers worked out a deal
where cohen returned for six episodes of
season nine of the walking dead
but then would leave immediately to star
on the abc spy dramedy whiskey cavalier
but it's a good thing cohen had her
walking dead safety net abc canceled the
show after one season
and luckily for fans cohen will return
to the undead series in 2020
the walking dead is known for being
brutal and they proved it by killing off
a main character who is also just a kid
the eighth season brought the death of
carl grimes
sheriff grimes son who grew up in a
zombified war-torn world and who no
longer represented a bright future
after his slow and emotional death from
a walker bite
but actor chandler riggs announced his
acceptance to auburn university
leading to speculation that he'd leave
the walking dead to focus on his studies
but not long after this news broke riggs
told the hollywood reporter that he'd
actually wanted to take a gap year
before college to focus on acting and
that leaving the walking dead wasn't his
decision
rig stated about his exit from the show
it was devastating for me and my family
because the show has been such a huge
part of my life for so long
for a few days we didn't know what to do
riggs had also recently purchased a
house in georgia where the walking dead
filmed
leading him to admit that was a big deal
that i wouldn't be on anymore
it was it was really weird because i
never thought that it would happen
because
my character is still alive in the
comics and he plays a pretty big role
throughout the comics so
the walking dead fans would argue that
the show went from good to great when
deny guerrera joined the cast in season
two
as michonne a mysterious warrior who
went from
wandering the wastes with two chained
walkers to being the leader of the
show's main survivor group while forming
a family with rick grimes and his
children
but guerrera announced that she was
leaving the walking dead after the
show's forthcoming 10th season she said
it at san diego comic con in 2019
i can confirm that this is the last
season i will be on this amazing tv show
as michonne
it is not connected to my heart my heart
stays right here
it was all about my calling and other
things i feel called to
the opportunities i've had exploring it
as a creator of work
and she's not just talking about her
work in film which includes her role as
okoye in black panther one of the
biggest movies of all time
guerrero seems to want to return to
being one of america's most renowned
playwrights
among her works are in the continuum and
eclipsed which
received a tony award for best play
while the walking dead is an ensemble
drama
sheriff rick grimes was always the main
character from the moment he woke up in
a hospital to a zombie ravaged world
later seasons found him reuniting with
his wife and son leading a group of
survivors
welcoming a baby daughter losing his
wife and son
and trying to rebuild some semblance of
a life that's an extremely
full plot arc for rick grimes and it was
also a lot of emotional lifting for
actor andrew lincoln
in 2018 lincoln announced that he would
leave the series during the ninth season
of the walking dead
lincoln told a crowd at san diego
comic-con i love this show
it means everything to me i love the
people that make this show
i suppose what i wanted to say is that
my relationship with mr grimes is far
from over
lincoln said he would reprise his role
of rick in three walking dead movies and
wanted to keep the regular role in his
life
but ultimately struggled to balance
family with work lincoln told the
hollywood reporter about his probable
return
what i would hope to see is rick grimes
again
but he doesn't look well the walking
dead shoots for months on end in georgia
far away from where he calls home in
england lincoln told ew radio
i have two young children and i live in
a different country
and they become less portable as they
get older it was that simple
it was time for me to come home lenny
james relationship with the walking dead
in its universe of amc shows is long and
complicated
his character morgan jones first serves
as a walking example of the increasing
physical and emotional
toll of life in the post-apocalyptic
zombie world
he helps rick acclimate to the new rules
of life after he emerges from his coma
the death of his wife and son left
morgan a broken man who goes on a
killing spree
until an encounter with the peaceful
survivor eastman instills in him a new
esteem for human life
while morgan appeared occasionally for
maximum impact he became a regular cast
member in season six
during the alexandria compound period he
left the show for good after season
eight moving over to walking dead sister
series fear the walking dead
joining a different group of survivors
trying to outlast zombie hordes earlier
in the timeline of the walking dead
halfway through season 7 and 2017
pollyanna mcintosh joined the walking
dead world as ann
or rather jadis a former antagonist and
leader of a survival group called the
scavengers
her last appearance came in the season 9
episode what comes after which is also
the last appearance of main character
rick grimes but in a show where regular
characters perishes a matter of course
rick doesn't die in this episode gravely
injured he's lifted to safety in a
helicopter after anne discovers his
barely living body
where is she taking rick what has she
got planned
it's almost certain all will be revealed
in a series of three the walking dead
spin-off movies
in which macintosh could play a critical
part reprising her role as anne
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the walking dead are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one